بعد التوحد وسكتات القلبيه والدماغيه
ومخاطر توريث فرط النشاط دراسه جديده من
جامعه ولايه اوهايو تجد ان الباراسيتامول
يزيد من سلوك المخاطره الدراسه التي نشرت
نتائجها مجله علم الاصابع عززت لائحه
الخطيره لاستهلاك المسكن الاكثر شعبيه
والمتوفر في الصيدليات بلاصفه اذ يبدو ان
الدواء الذي يباع الانفاق واسع تحت اسماء
تجاريه مختلفه يزيد من سلوك المخاطره في
العقار بحسب الباحثين يجعل الناس يشعرون
بمشاعر سلبيه اقل عندما يفكروه في انشطه
محفوفه بالمخاطر مثل القفز بالمظلات
والتعبير عن راي غير الشعبي في الاماكن
العامه فلا يشعرون بالخوف
[موسيقى]
يبدو ان اثار الفرس تمول المستخدم للحد من
الالم تمتد الى العمليات النفسيه المختلفه
الذي يسبب انخفاض التعاطف وحتى اضعاف
الوظائف المعرفيه بحسب الدراسات فيما وجدت
دراسه حديثه من استخدام طويل الامادي
لمسكن باراسيتا مول يزيد من احتماليه
الاصابه بامراض القلب والسكته الدماغيه
لدى مرضى ارتفاع ضغط الدم ينحوي 20 بالمئه
ونبهه دراسه بريطانيه الى نتناول
الباراسيتامول المسكنه في منتصف فتره
الحمل يعرض المواليد لخطر فرط النشاط
ومشاكل انتباه والسلوكيات الصعبه الاخرى
بين السنه سته اشهر والاحد عشر عاما وخرج
الدراسه من الجامعه
مول انت الى الصعوبات والمشاكل في النطق
عند الفتيات اللواتي تتناولت امهاتهم تلك
الحبوب المسكنه اثناء الحمل
[موسيقى]
ينضم لنا في الفيديو الصيدلي احمد مصطفى
احمد اهلا بك يسعد صباحك طيب المسكن
المسكن الالم اكثر شيوعا وشعبيه في العالم
الدراسه تقول انه يزيد من سلوك المخاطره
الى اما دقيقه هذه الدراسه
يمكن شرائها بدون وصفه طبيه بس نتكلم على
الدراسه دي بالتحديد على زياده نسبه
المخاطره او التهور عند الناس اللي ممكن
تستخدم همم الباراسيتامول فهي كان دراسه
على بعض الطلاب الجامعيين اللي بيحاولوا
يشوفوا تاثير الباراسيتامول على همم
سلوك المخاطر الموجود عندهم بس يمكن لو
احنا ركزنا في الملك هو همم او مركب
الباراستامول يمكن خطورته الاكبر على
مستوى اا بعض الاعراض الجانبيه اللي ممكن
تحصل منه نتيجه الافراط في الجرعه زي
تاثيره على وظائف الكبد احيانا لا قدر
الله بيوصل للفشل الكبدي نتيجه الافراط في
استخدام الباراسيتامول الجرعه عاليه ومع
ذلك هو ما زال يعتبر من ائمن المسكنات لا
يمكن همم استخدامها همم
على مستوى العالم كمان على المستوى همم
اذا بعد اليوم واذا في حال اثبتت هذه
الدراسه راح تصيروا خلاص انه اذا حدا بده
يشترك على السيتامول او انواع لازم تكون
وصفه طبيه هذه مره بس انا باتكلم على همم
يمكن الدراسه دي مش هي اللي تخوفنا من
البارز والاكتر يمكن من قبل كده من حوالي
40 50 سنه من ساعه ما قلت بالتثيره همم
اعراض جانبيه على مستوى الكبد او غيره وهو
ده يمكن الخطر الاكبر يعني بس طبعا باي
تايم انت بتلاقي ان في اعراض جانبيه جديده
بتحصل ومشكله الباراسيتامول لان الامهات
بتدي له كل الاطفال
ولما بيسخنوا همم في اي دور برد او غيره
فبالتالي بيبقى ساعات في افراط في الجرعه
وده اللي بياثر بعد كده همم بنشوف دلوقت
مثلا نسبه الاطفال اللي بيجيء لهم اعراض
فرط التوحد واا
تذكرت هذا الموضوع لانه انت ركزت على
الاثار المتعلقه همم بالاعضاء يعني اثار
العضويه اليوم نتحدث عن من مسكن الم الى
الى اثار نفسيه تحدث الدراسه
بماذا تنصح الناس قبل اخذ البراسيتامول او
البنادول الحقيقه هو الاهم هو همم لما
بيتم اخذ همم عقار الفارس اسطنبول هو
الالتزام بالجرعات المحدده وعدم الافراط
فيه يعني احنا اكثر حاجه الامهات لما
خصوصا على المستوى التاثير النفسي على
الاطفال انه يزود فرطه الحركه التوحد اهم
حاجه بالنسبه للامهات ان ما تستخدميهوش زي
ما بيقولوا في مصر على الفاضي على المليان
يعني الطفل حاولي تستخدمي الاساليب الاخرى
اللي تقلل درجه الحراره وتخلي استخدام
الباراسيتامول عند الحاجه القصوى وده امان
لطفلك بصفه عامه يعني
الائمه
اللي بيطلق عليها همم
النوع ده من الادويه ما زال ليس اامن من
البارامو لكن هو مازال بديل زي همم
الديكلوفي هناك مركب بدون ذكر اسماء
تجاريه همم والايبوجروفون
احمد واسماءها يعني انت تقول انه نرجع انا
بدائل ثانيه غير الدواء يعني قبل الم انا
بدي مسكن الم في البيت في بدائل الاعشاب
بدائل اخرى غير الدواء دائما انا همم يعني
بالنسبه لموضوع القلم لما هاحتاج مسكن
خلاص ممكن ناخذ بس لازم همم يعني ادرس ايه
التريجرز وراء القلم ده يعني هل الصداع
الموز من اللي بيجيء لي او همم
[موسيقى]
مش مش طبيعي ومش منطقي
فبالتالي ان انا لما اعرف السبب ده يغنيني
ان انا افضل استخدم المسكن بشكل همم مستمر
وبجراعات عاليه لمده همم
جزيلا احمد مصطفى الصيدلي نورتنا في
الاستديو شكرا